the commercial break he were started to
talk about another girlfriend oh man how
was my baby girls Hugh Spanish yeah she
was hairy I was seventeen I never seen a
woman that much here yeah yeah here on
her nipples oh she did I said if I get
this girl pregnant my baby gonna come
out looking like Chaka from Land at a
loss Tracey is this true you bought
yourself a new car a lot of people go up
and buy themselves a new car you bought
yourself an incredibly nice car you
bought yourself a Bugatti that's one of
the nicest fanciest cars in the world
but you never forget your first car
think dream about my first car my first
car look like Chitty Chitty Bang Bang
is that true yeah I love my Bugatti
though so you're sentimental about your
old car but you really like this Bugatti
the Bugatti does to do it 300 miles per
hour some 100 1204 450 horsepower and I
was driving it around in my neighborhood
I live in a very affluent neighborhood
now mm-hmm
so these young kids who hey mister how
fast is she God said I'd drive his car
like a pimp you're yelling miles per
hour yes I kids yeah one car crash is
enough yeah so you got this new car and
you're happy with it you you you gonna
say I'm happy with it why not cuz I want
a space shuttle
[Laughter]
[Applause]
I'm good nada you like he won out the
present moment I was scraping up change
right now to move to Canada
let's go journey you have a book just so
the Bugatti and you can go to Canada now
I'm taking a Bugatti with okay
you